what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with invincible yes volume 21
modern family uh honestly we have like i
think maybe five volumes left uh and
then we're completely finished like the
run is totally over uh yeah so there's a
few things to know going into this right
like some of the invincible comics that
we've done so far there's a lot of like
talking a lot of in-between things and
then there's like the main story itself
and the main story itself deals with the
return of battle beasts so one of the
first things to happen here is that in
the aftermath of rex basically
conquering earth right basically taking
it over despite how it is that he might
phrase it uh this has led to a few
different things specifically with mark
and this struggle with the idea of rex
basically running the whole world and
ultimately one of the things that he
tells adam eve is that no matter how
hard he tries no matter how hard he
works or whatever effort he puts in that
he will always oppose
rex robot that he'll never be able to
ally himself with them and that if he
continues to stay on earth eventually
he'll end up going to war with him so
the only thing that he can really see
himself doing given the current
circumstance the fact that he's got adam
eve to take care of the fact that he's
got a child to take care of the only
thing they can really do now is really
just leave the world right it's just is
walk away because he doesn't really see
things getting better than where they
already are that ultimately he's just
going to see things getting increasingly
worse and so what he ends up doing here
and it's kind of interesting there's a
couple takeaways from this that'll be
important later on the first thing is
really him just kind of saying goodbye
to the people that he knows some of whom
who are basically telling him like it's
your responsibility to stay here on
earth it's your responsibility to be a
superhero even if you don't necessarily
agree with everything that rex is doing
it's your job to basically stay here and
to ensure he doesn't get too far out of
control but the response of mark largely
is no like i've got a family to support
now right i've got a family to take care
of i've got like a child and i've got a
wife right my duty is to them to make
sure they're safe humanity the entire
human race in this world is not more
important than them and even if it was
the world chose what it wanted right it
decided that it wanted this it decided
to side with rex robot and so whatever
fate befalls it it basically has coming
right it's called consequences
and so one of the other things that
happens here is you also get this kind
of meeting with robot rex where
basically mark is kind of taken around
to a degree and shown what's happening
here that when the two of them encounter
each other that mark says like you're
certainly on top of things and rex says
like of course i am he says that was the
whole point of this mark to have someone
in charge who could be on top of things
even you have to admit things are better
than they were before and he says you
can be in denial all you want but i know
you're smart enough to see the truth
being here stepping in are you ready to
work together again have you come to see
my side of things and the response of
mark is no you're smart enough to know
that will never ever happen
and so it's one of those things where
rex like okay fine like i find your
resistance to be kind of a troubling
thing uh but as long as you don't
interfere then that's cool right but
it's one of those things we're kind of
like looking around rex is basically
making the world a better place and if
humanity goes along with it then that
basically means humanity's accepting of
it right because one of the things that
rex has basically said here is humanity
will never see anything other than just
an uptick in their quality of life now
as we know rex made a huge amount of
mistakes when it came to like the whole
alien dimension and everything there's
nothing to indicate that won't be the
case here more so than that there's
trouble in paradise that there comes a
point when sinclair basically meets with
mark and of course sinclair was the one
who's creating like robots and he's the
mad scientist from when mark was in
college and so on so the two have a
pretty sketchy history but what he says
is he's like rex is gone right he cannot
hear us he can't hear what we're talking
about something that you need to
understand he's not made a whole lot of
friends when it comes to the global
defense agency so if you were to form
some kind of counter group just
understand you would have allies there
are people who want to see him go down
now the motivation as to why we don't
know one of the things you also have to
keep in mind is that if rex undertakes
it on himself to basically create all
these robots to basically keep the world
a better place then if there's no war
there's a lot of people who aren't
making money and so you have to believe
that a lot of this is like financially
motivated and so it's one of those
things where ultimately you end up
having mark and adam eve who basically
take their baby and effectively leave
earth now again it's saying goodbye to
like nolan it's mark saying goodbye to
his mom you know it's like adam e saying
goodbye to her family and her dad just
giving her all kinds of hell but
ultimately basically turning over a new
leaf something that he's never really
done before where he was like we love
you right because her dad was always
just a dick right and even her parents
were they were always just kind of
really crappy people to her but
ultimately it's the best decision for
them because being able to just kind of
leave the world and essentially hit the
reset button on their lives to a degree
it works right or at least it seems to
work it allows them to just kind of
start off somewhere fresh and there is
power in being able to just hit the
giant red reset button in your life one
of the most empowering things you could
possibly do right take everything you
know everything that you've you've cared
about to a degree maintain those
connections but in turn move away from
it all right just be out there on your
yo in your life on your own and having
nothing more than just your wits and
your fortitude and your resolve to get
you through if you were able to pull
that off successfully you would be
astounded by the kind of things that you
can achieve and how much confidence you
build in yourself and that's really kind
of what they're doing right what they're
doing is really more of the cosmic
equivalent of you moving to a different
state away from like the safety of your
family
right abandoning the safety net and just
relying on yourself and so one of the
things that kind of happens here and
it's kind of a funny little moment is
they basically refer to their daughter
as tara or actually name their daughter
tara which is pretty adorable right in
the sense that it's kind of like okay
you know like you know it's our little
slice of earth right you know so earth
is referred to as as taran where the
people on earth are terrance so you know
we'll call our kids you call our
daughter tara and once they actually get
to like telesco right the home world of
the coalition of of planets and all that
kind of stuff they basically start to
settle in of course oliver has basically
aged up pretty drastically because
remember he ages about half as fast as
his mother's race but he still ages much
faster than like a viltromite or even
just a regular human he's not really you
know a human at all but nonetheless you
know he ages incredibly fast uh but then
you also have this moment when like he
brings over his girl named haluma uh
which is like this crazy alien looking
thing but apparently she also makes some
pretty wild food which looks crazy as
hell but also tastes delicious of course
it gives mark the the craps the the
absolute you know deuces in the worst
way but one of the big things that
happens here is you actually end up
having this conversation between mark
and adam eve when mark basically reveals
that he was sexually assaulted by anissa
right the villager might and one of the
things about this and that's what's kind
of interesting is that adam eve is very
consoling here there isn't much anger
from her you know against anissa it's
really more her just kind of feeling
feeling bad for mark right consoling
mark as best she can and saying like
we'll get through this that kind of a
thing but the other part of this and
mark kind of takes this blame on himself
which is actually a victim mentality
that you usually see when it comes to a
victim of sexual assault uh part of him
is kind of like i couldn't fight her off
as much as i i i should have right like
i wasn't able to get her to stop maybe
it's because some part of me actually
wanted it to happen right it's
internalizing the the assault that he
went through and basically blaming it on
himself that is a well-documented result
of people who are victims of all kinds
of assault right any kind of heinous
situations but especially when it comes
to uh kind of a violent assault in that
way and so of course this also leads to
them realizing their baby's not
breathing right you know once everything
kind of kind of goes nuts as you guys
can tell we're kind of pushing through a
lot of this stuff because we need to get
to like the whole battle beast thing but
basically it's them learning how to be
parents right is really all it is right
it's them just kind of learning how to
be parents in this world uh and one of
the other big things too is like
literally when they're in the hospital
oliver and uh and his girls show up and
mark's like what did you feed us she was
like you bought a you brought a baby to
an alien planet you [ __ ] like think
about the radiation from like a
different sun or the particles in the
air or any kind of germ or bacteria that
she might not have resistance to like
literally you brought your child from
earth to an alien world knowing nothing
about this alien world or anything in
relation to whether or not this baby
would survive right like you're an idiot
and you're paying the price for your
idiocy
of course their baby ends up surviving
right their baby's fine uh and it's just
kind of one of those things where it's
like whatever was that adam eve ate was
basically passed on to the baby through
breastfeeding right so basically it
really was the food of oliver's girl but
what we end up doing here is switching
over to mark being given an assignment
by alan the alien essentially mark is to
a degree gonna be a spy more of a
detective than anything else but
basically just kind of keeping an eye on
the on the planet of telescope and
reporting in if anything like dangerous
or crazy is happening it's very much
like kind of a cushy office job to a
degree because alan alien realizes that
mark's got like adam eve and he's got
his child and stuff like that and he
doesn't want to put him in danger right
he doesn't want to put him in a
situation where he's going to end up
getting killed unfortunately that's
exactly what happens that like when he's
at home with adam eve allen visits him
and says okay uh so right now battle
beast is fighting thrag and we don't
think he's going to succeed uh we need
you to go find thrag while he's in a
weakened state and basically take him
out now this is when we switch over to
the fight between battle beast and thrag
and this fight is
nuts it's absolutely intense so wind the
clock back a little bit right because
technically the fight kind of happened
in the beginning of the comic right so
the whole thing behind this is that
there's two things happening the first
is that if you guys recall the planet
that nolan traveled to where he met the
race where he ended up having oliver
thrag is on that planet as well the
difference is that unlike nolan who took
like a singular wife thrag is banging
them all right freddie mercury is
banging every single one of these girls
and basically just like rapidly
populating the viltrumite race they're
not pure viltrumites but basically it's
an army of olivers it's really what
we're talking about here and i mean
there's dozens upon dozens of these
right it just keeps going and going and
going and so as a result of this the
fight that happens between battle beast
and thrag is really really cool here
because of course battlebeast basically
has this girl right the chick that's
with him and then once he arrives to the
planet where thrag is located battle
beast immediately takes off and starts
going after thrag now of course they
fought before and ferdie mercury beat
the hell out of battle beast and that's
why he's kind of like okay like if you
want to do this again we can but like i
crushed you pretty easily last time now
the other downside to this is that as we
know the ragnars are very dangerous in
relation to vulture mites they're one of
the only races out there that can
actually kill viltrumites one of the
things that happens is that the girl of
battle beasts unleashes these on on
basically their location to try to kill
freddie mercury and the reason why is
because of the fact that she promised
alan alien she wouldn't let battle beast
die the issue is that as you guys know
battlebeast is an honorable fighter so
when he faces somebody that he thinks is
a worthy threat like literally he wants
an honorable fair fight the guy does not
cheat if he comes out on top he wants to
know it's because he did it of his own
accord right his own wits fortitude
whatever he was able to pull it off
without any assistance so in fact he
actually helps freddie mercury kill all
these ragnars that are there and while
freddie mercury is injured in the
process the forces of freddie mercury
basically his alien troops come to come
to the rescue and then he tells them
leave right like this is a fight between
me and battlebeast now because of the
fact that freddie mercury is injured
battlebeats in turn injures himself in a
likened way in order to even the playing
field as much as possible and this fight
between the two is knock down drag out
right it's one of the most bloody fights
you're ever gonna see and that's the
thing is battle beast and thrag neither
of them will give it up right neither
one of them is willing to like retreat
or concede or anything and it's just
brutal in the most extreme we're talking
about broken bones all kinds of stuff
and so once you get to this moment where
you basically have uh you know mark
being contacted by alan alien the fight
is such where it basically looks like
battle beast has gained the upper hand
like i mean he's taking like chunks out
of out of freddie mercury right like
just bitten huge chunks out of him but
the reality is that because this fight
is so intense because freddie mercury's
been around for so long and because he's
so incredibly strong so battle-hardened
in the end his kind of bloodlust
basically overtakes him and when that
happens he gains the upper hand on
battle beast and in doing so literally
just kills him like just rips him apart
just rips his guts out and everything
and like that's the end of battle beast
right battle beast is basically dead
here and it's kind of nuts because what
you get is basically the the fallout of
like mark and oliver and those guys
arriving on the scene of this world and
one of the things oliver says is that
because his mother's race has such an
incredibly short life anybody on this
world who would have known who oliver or
even nolan were they've long since been
gone right they've been dead for quite
some time and so all you really have are
just maybe like their grandchildren or
great-grandchildren or what have you but
freddie mercury was basically their
leader and they revered him right that's
one of the things you guys probably
recall from nolan is that he probably
saved them from some threat and they
were like we'll do whatever you want to
right they saw him as just a great and
honorable guy hence the reason why he
started banging all the girls and so
what this does is you basically see the
arrival of a member of this race meeting
with oliver and uh and and mark in
saying yeah the being you call battle
beast was killed by our leader he was
destroyed and we burned his body at a
pyre some time ago you know in a kind of
celebration of of his his death and
destruction and so at that point he's
like you know basically the leader you
know our you know freddie mercury took
as many women as he possibly could and
then took a whole bunch of their
soldiers and took off into space to
basically go and do whatever it is that
he was going to do and so what you find
out is of course uh when he shows up
here it's kind of nuts he basically
skinned battle beast like he literally
he skinned it which i'm not even gonna
lie battle beast draped around his
shoulders looks pretty badass like i'm
not even gonna lie man it looks pretty
legit but like he killed battlebeast and
he's continuing the process of just
procreating with all of all the members
of this alien race as much as he can
that while it's not a perfect substitute
to the vulture might race as they
existed before given what we've seen
with oliver they're all very like
they're going to be very very very very
powerful enough so that if they all end
up going to war against the coalition of
planets they'll probably be able to
topple it so yeah understand freddie
mercury's down but this guy's far from
out with that being said guys we're
going to bring this to an end thank you
all for watching and i will catch you
all later
peace